welcome to this video playing Grand
Master are oddly yeah this is a much
about his first name Ahmed oddly yeah
well junior champion to tolleson is a
very strong GM 2600 player okay let's go
with my queen bee three line and never
played him right yeah I've seen him on
the ICC but he's not a very it's not a
frequent opponent so first game I have
against him so we transpose to some kind
of Queens gambit declined he answered
with e6 that sir I'm good good reply
okay so is he going to take on c3 this
is a the takes on c3 its server is
similar to to Alaska variation very
really sound and solid way for black to
play okay is some probably aiming to
play em play 'if I've going to play work
t1 which prevents if I for the moment
because of group d 8 at the end of those
lines DC beach Bishop takes you five
take take everything at the end rookie 8
and wide wins so he cannot go if I've
now not sure this is maybe a slightly
worse version of the lusca it's not so
easy to see what is movies now be 6 i'm
trading on d5 yeah this is possible at
term okay yeah maybe just take this is
the easiest way to play this this always
should be a slide slide edge for white
94 maybe no he's covering it didn't
expect that at all cover the debt that
weakens c6 quite a bit how is he playing
this may be here not sure can also week
in my position but and maybe you can
take on d3 play Bishop f5 or something
like that
hmm Jerry I took it Queen takes Queen
before it's probably no good so I have
to check with the rook now if I take on
d5 he can play em he can play a rook c8
I want the knight on d4 and Bishop g4 is
a bit bit of an issue one look to you
won't even play Bishop g4 I guess rook
t4 looks very unharmonious and okay
maybe I'm going back Bishop g4 I I have
moves like windy for for example so
should be quite ok I think he has to do
that otherwise he has no no kind of
compensation for the for structural
problems with the pawn this this should
be ok for him I guess in some way ok I'm
not not sure ok Queen g5 I intended
Queen g4 but he can take and play rookie
for double attacking
yeah maybe just keep this protected
so that now I'm I'm really threat down
upon yeah Queen g4 I thought that's
probably King moves are not helping but
this way i'm forcing traits rook 1c8
also hangs
I can take see one that's an idea and
then move the Queen
yeah probably rooks see one
not totally certain but if he takes on
g4 I'm not sure maybe I still have a
very slight pull against is this
isolated pawn but yeah this is better
and now move the Queen to e5 for example
it makes quite a bit of sense and he has
ideas like rookie five now okay rook c8
to trade rooks maybe I just make let us
make sense if he goes rookie five is a
bit of a tricky business so let's see if
i can get this traded check recheck Jeff
and then go to d3
Queen g6 should be okay for me he still
has the d5 pawn weakness it's not clear
his king is more active but hard to
believe I'm worse after that I expect g6
or this one I know I can actually draw
yeah significantly this for when I mean
I can win on time I could try to win on
time but okay he wants to continue I'm
blundering a pod ah what the heck come
on the only way to lose this bloody game
is gifting a new pawn yeah I can just
play King g2 and never ever lose ya
check idiotic simply idiotic the
absolute only way to lose I found them
great great may I come on him get this
point right resides blundering the pawn
in one move yeah the whole game he is
struggling to equalize this okay it's a
draw okay let's make a draw and I picked
green d3 and give him the pawn in one
move so idiotic is that check yeah just
just something and he can never ever
ever ever can why lose him yeah just
keeping the King's I protected put the
Queen on d3 I mean yes he basically has
to check I mean continuing was quite
quite cheeky but okay if I blunder the
born in one move let's let's just
continue him yeah simply simply idiotic
and of course I should have kept an
advantage here because here white white
should be better as well
I'm probably Bishop to I don't know this
this is probably okay yeah this should
equalize check yeah it's just very equal
check they did a bit i'm a bit softer
more ideas to to play more actively
maybe i should have done that but um
yeah yeah i lost three games in a row
this is a fourth game in a row so i tend
to play on the on the safe side but well
this is maybe for the guys who wrote
yeah i'm uploading my wins not my losses
here there are four losses in a row hope
you enjoy them okay thanks for watching
guys